[Music]
Steve Harvey lays down the law and a
blistering memo that has just been
leaked telling you staff at times not to
approach him or even speak to him the
memo lit up social media and a lot of
people jump to the conclusion that Steve
was on some kind of power trip so what
was really going through his mind I
found out when I talked to Steve
exclusively by phone today so Steve what
happened with the memo
I probably begin in a year because I was
trying to find our way that I could just
get more bleep time time for me I'm a 16
year old man and I could not find a way
to walk from the stage to my dressing
room to sit in the makeup chair to walk
to my dressing room to the stage but you
just did me have lunch well somebody
just walking in Steve Harvey spoke to us
exclusively this morning from Chicago
where his talk show is wrapping up its
last day of production before it's moved
to LA in a startling memo to staffers
that just leaked Harvey rope quote there
will be no meetings in my dressing room
no stopping by or popping in no one do
not come to my dressing room and les
invited do not open my dressing room
door it goes on if you open my door
expect to be removed my security team
will stop everyone from standing at my
door who have the intent to see or speak
to me Steve told me he sent the memo
because some staffers were taking
advantage of his open-door policy I'm in
the hallway I'm getting ambushed by
people with fans that come to the show
and everything fine listen Judith I just
said wait a me
so who leaked the memo well Steve has
some suspicions Stephen everybody knows
the show is moving to Los Angeles a
couple of people are not happy with that
they're disgruntled so why would you
wait until the end of the season to
report something that I'm getting you
back in August and we just simply asking
everybody to honor and respect that
look man anybody did you come out your
house you don't want a buddy on your
porch waiting on you you won't get your
car you don't want people bother you on
the way to come everybody wants to
freedom did we move around I just didn't
want to be in this prison
more why I had to stay in this one
little wound scared to go out and take a
fresh breath of fresh air without
somebody approached me so I wrote the
letter man I don't apologize about the
letter but sounded crazy what people
keep just saying it ran but I appreciate
you asking me
[Music]
you